في هذه الاثناء اعلن الكريم لاننا روسيا
ما تزال منفتح على المحادثات مع اوكرانيا
و بشان ما نشرته صحيفه وصفت جورنال عن
نجوي مستشار الامن القومي الامريكي جيك
سوليفان محادثات سريه مع الجانب الروسي
اعتبر الكريم لان وسائل الاعلام البريطاني
احوال الامريكيه تريد الكثير مما وصفها
بالمعلومات الكاتبه
وكانت الصحيفه قد نقلت عن مسؤولينا ان
مستشار الامن القومي
سريه مع كباره مساعد رئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين في محاوله للحد من مخاطر نشوب صراع
اوسع حول اوكرانيا لتحضيري موسكو من مغبه
المسؤولون ان المحادثات السريه التي جرت
في الاشهر الاخيره بين سلفا ونظيره
سكر
القنوات مفتوحه وليست لمناقشه تسويه للحرب
نقلت صحيفه مسؤول امريكي